salut brune devenue chez moi pas du tout
je suis bien habillé ça change un peu du
jogging bon allez venez suivre jusqu'à
la montée des marches franchement ça va
je pensais que j'allais plus stressé que
ça à mon avis ça va être sur les marches
enfin sur le tapis quand je vais arriver
qu'on va me dire c'est à toi que je dois
faire des pauses du genre
ça va pas le faire des zooms et on va
improviser ça va le faire j'étais fier
en même temps je me disais pourquoi moi
c'est un peu étrange comme sentiment
servant de l'imposteur tout le temps et
j'ai envie de dire croyez tout sans vos
rêves ne sait-on jamais tout peut
arriver donc fond c'est peut-être qu'un
jour j'arriverai sur un endroit comme ça
je me dirais c'est bon j'ai ma place ici
peut-être pas peut-être que tous les
jours je me dirai ce que je fais là